crunch or tease me capping
crunchy tease me captain what does that
mean
cereal the breakfast of people who are
too lazy to make anything cereal is one
of the greatest things and today
i am going to be eating some british
cereals and on the other end i have sent
adda
buzzfeed producer and real-life british
person some american cereals and the two
are surprisingly different i love cereal
because
all you need is milk cereal and a bone
[Music]
cap and crunch oh my god there's like a
word search on the back british cereal
doesn't have games with it i like the
captain
crunch or tease me capping what does
that mean
oh sugar straight away okay
i see where this is going i predict a
good time
slaps i can feel the sugar going through
my hands i can see why people are
into it it tastes good but like i don't
know how you give this to kids before it
goes
captain oh i salute you next up we got
this monstrosity
weedabix the name weetabix does not do
it for me
how is this britain's favorite cereal
even that logo it's
shaped like a capsule this is medicine i
don't want to eat
medicine for breakfast this kind of fell
apart a little bit oops
let's try to get one intact one out of
here this looks
like horse food i don't even know what's
holding it together is it like
sheer force of will i'm not giving this
a fair shot let's pour some milk into
this because apparently you're supposed
to let it get a little bit soggy
or something mash it up with your big
boy spoon
let's see at least it's high in fiber so
my shoes are going to be good
soaking it in the milk makes it better
somehow
this is growing on me as i eat more of
it yes it's a soggy mush
and yes it doesn't have really any
flavor but like
it's kind of satisfying to eat grape
nuts which i don't know it's like
something that your mum would like make
you eat when you had like constipation
or something
damn maybe i do need these group notes
because i'm weak
it doesn't look great
it tastes like the cardboard box it came
in like it's not even softening up with
the milk it's
it's pretty solid what is this
ah i'm chewing for so long power 3 power
3 power 3.
nah why why would you do this to people
honey monster
ada said it was good she said she used
to eat it when she was a kid
it's got vitamins sorry it's got
vitamins
his eyes are just staring deep into my
soul
and making me question all my life
decisions up to this point and really
making me want cereal
let's eat some honey monster this is a
big box this is what they'd call
in america a single serving
i use the big boy spoon because i'm a
big boy now mom
yeah the texture is definitely kind of
like puffed rice the cereal
is already starting to get soggy and
it's been in this bowl for like
20 seconds because it's not too sweet
the honey isn't an overpowering flavor
you can still taste the the green
underneath it it tastes like the healthy
kind of sweet rather than the
just sugary kind of sweet next on the
list the old
reese's peepers i know about reese's the
chocolaty things the only ones
i've had were filled with like weed when
i went to la so
those are really fun i don't know if
it's going to give me the same
amount of excitement
[Music]
if you've got another allergy this ain't
for you boo that is potent
you've got these little balls a dark
ball and a light ball
[Music]
unity
i think this cereal is all smell because
like the smell was like
i've stuck two peanut butter chunks up
my nose and it's entered my brain
but then the taste ate that peanut
buttery i think it was quite nice it
definitely wasn't as sugary as
and crunch so it's like more on my level
that's my favorite so far because it
wasn't too much
curiously cinnamon this one reminds me a
lot of like cinnamon toast crunch
i like these little guys on it i like
their eyes i always have found it a bit
weird when companies anthropomorphized
foods that you're eating because it's
just like why are you giving the thing
that i'm eating a face
pour that cinnamon in there there's like
little patterns on the cereals
that's a lot like cinnamon toast crunch
but these pieces are a little bit like
puffier i guess
they seem a little bit denser i do
really like it though wow i am 25 years
old
and eating cereal at 7 pm thriving
as with the honey monster the cinnamon
flavor on this isn't super overpowering
it's subtle enough that you still get
the flavor but you can also taste the
underlying grain of the cereal which is
nice because it kind of balances the
sweetness out a little bit
so sour patch kids ah
kids you are gonna be buzzing your tits
off after you have this if you're going
to school has a thing on the back
you wake up in a blank place crack then
i'm so sorry oh my god
you cannot tell me
you guys are given this to kids
in the morning i'm starting to
understand america's health problems
i don't have to eat another world that
is sweet and sour like a sour patch kid
you might as well just put the gummy
bears and then put some milk on it
i'm sorry i'm apologizing to my stomach
you are gonna hurt yourself straight
after this
i can't eat it the second that touched
my mouth was like nah i'm sorry i can't
believe i just spat that out i cannot
believe that this is even the product
you guys are crazy that was an
experience
crave they're not even trying to
disguise the fact that this
is straight sugar i was talking to adam
before this
and she was like oh american cereals are
so sweet and then you come at me with
this
little just chocolate inside a cereal
i don't know what i expected it just
tastes like milk chocolate
wrapped in cereal the actual cereal
outside itself is actually pretty
flavorless you break through it into the
chocolate
and the chocolate has such a strong
sweet flavor that you forget
that the outside was flavorless i do
like it but
it is so sweet i'm definitely not gonna
be able to eat this whole bowl right now
if i were a child
i would think this was perfect i thought
i wasn't gonna finish it
but i'm lying to myself if i say that i
don't like sweet things i am still a
child i'm just trying not to be
[Music]
american cereals yeah you guys are doing
too much
i hope dakota has fun with the cereals i
said to him like we went through sugar
attacks and then the government started
attacks and sugar more and then like all
of our stuff kind of got a bit blander
i might actually finish the reese's
thesis because that was hidden like that
was really
hidden but the rest of them i'm gonna
give them to my boyfriend
or i have siblings so what do we learn
here today we learned that british
cereal can be
just as sweet as american cereal i'm
gonna say my favorite cereal today
was probably curiously cinnamon overall
i'm a pretty happy guy i've got four
boxes
of cereal here that i can eat for the
next uh week or two for breakfast and
what's better than that thank you so
much for watching don't forget to like
and subscribe
and let me know what your favorite
cereal from your country is and maybe
i'll try it sometime
[Music]